Kings Kings and More Kings here's
everything you need to know about those
post-credit scenes in Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania warning spoilers ahead
the third Ant-Man adventure takes Scott
hope and the rest of the extended ant
family to a familiar place that hides
some terrifying Secrets Scott Lang's
crafty daughter Cassie and his mentor
girlfriend's dad Hank Pym have been
conducting tests on the quantum realm
only for things to go horribly awry as
Scott Cassie Hank hope and Janet get
sucked into an increasingly mysterious
series of mini worlds it turns out that
they're facing a terrifying and complex
adversary Kang the Conqueror and it
seems that Kang has quite the bone to
pick with our heroes
you're an interesting man
Scotland
quantumania is a colorful high octane
science fiction story that functions as
an important showcase for impeding
Marvel Cinematic Universe big bad Kang
but does it follow the long-serving MCU
tradition of post-credit scenes come on
of course it does King remains front and
center in the film's two post-credit
scenes in fact even if you've been
yearning to see even more of the
character after Loki and quantumania
then the mid-credit scene might just be
what you bargained for we start with
three very different looking Kings
discussing the defeat of the exiled
Quantum realm variant and why the hero's
Victory is so unnerving we're then taken
to a huge Coliseum where countless kings
are arriving a number of them display
bloodthirsty and even animalistic traits
hooting and hollering like they are
about to go to war who knows this may
turn out to be Kang's version of this
scene from Age of Ultron
fun
I'll do it myself
the movie's main Kang is already a
complex character who balances between
deep regret unbridled Fury and a morsel
of kindness that only makes his worst
traits more terrible to behold compare
him with Loki's resigned and clownish he
who remains and this Congregation of
kings and we can only speculate on what
Jonathan Majors Master Class awaits when
Kang next returns
[Music]
if you thought Majors was good at
switching up his King performances
before the second post-credits scene
takes things to a completely different
level the scene presumably serves as a
teaser for Loki season 2 as we meet the
titular trickster God and Mobius M
Mobius as they observe a bumbling geeky
Kang variant in what appears to be a
turn of the 20th century setting giving
a science show demonstration of a
time-themed invention as Loki attempts
to convince the suspicious Mobius that
the man they're watching is extremely
dangerous the more comic Savvy viewers
may be busy with the chill running down
their spines this variant is named
Victor timely and he's a very special
character in the comics the timely Kang
is actually the original version of the
character called hang Prime he's the guy
who started the whole variant Thing by
traveling back in time to be a pharaoh
for a while soon finding himself in
conflict with Earth's Mightiest Heroes
the Victor timely disguise is one of
King Prime's major bids to power a
seemingly benevolent inventor and
industrialist who presides over an
entire time-themed city posing as a
rotating generation final cast of
Fathers and Sons while making all sorts
of moves behind the scenes interestingly
this king is also connected to Major
Loki character ravana rensslayer so if
even a fragment of timely's comic book
story makes it into the show Loki season
2 will be a pretty interesting watch
[Music]